the Joe Rogan experience so there's
certainly part of that but the thing is
that wouldn't explain why Trump has been
skeptical of the global financial system
since like 1978 right like there's that
old clip of him on Oprah in like 1980
about Japan and Jade I mean he's he's
even I've heard this from a friend he
was citing like one of my friends
michael lind who's like very you know
like a nationalist on trade policy in
the mid-2000s was like michael lind is
right about trade like he was he's
clearly been thinking about this for a
long time and on immigration in
particular I mean I think that's another
one where he's always kind of been there
he's always had the instant I mean his
real genius was looking at what did the
base of the Republican Party actually
want they want better trade deals and
they want less immigration and for you
know decades now all the professional
right has been able to give them is will
cut your taxes that's a priority
it'll never actually happen and then
that is that and then alt but you still
have to vote for us because we're good
on abortion and we're good on gun
control and that wasn't enough for a lot
of people and you can see - and this is
what I meant about making it a cynical
choice when you adjust your position on
immigration and on trade you win all of
these Obama Trump voters all throughout
the Midwest and you become the president
I mean and even then the I'm not saying
it was enough there still is a lot of
more work to be done I think it needs to
realign more to the issues of what I'm
talking about
but to say that it's all just it is just
I mean that's not his his driving force
like if you see the way I'm having
interacted with him and just like how he
how he reacts to certain things there
isn't condensed ideology behind what he
is otherwise he wouldn't have run the
way was he wouldn't have had those
positions for such a long time on the
core issues that actually matter to why
he was elected and so the real issue and
I think the criticism of valid criticism
is he wasn't able to enact those
political instincts into the actual
staffing of the White House because in
the White House personnel is policy and
there's a great there's a great book
called the years of Lyndon Johnson then
it's about history of LBJ has four
volumes and all that Robert acara one of
the best biographers of all time and he
quotes a guy named Tommy Corcoran who
was FDR's kind of right-hand man he's
like what is a government government's
not one-man government is a first
first thousand they all have to be
united in the common purpose in order to
actually get [ __ ] done in a bureaucracy
the truth is and we have to acknowledge
this is that on the right after Trump's
election the RNC and all these
professional right-wingers these
conservative establishment they were the
thousand and so that's why you get
something like the tax cuts bill the tax
cuts and Jobs Act it's because a guy
like you know Paul Ryan has been
fantasizing about pushing that for such
a long time he didn't agree with Trump
on trade he blatantly disagree you
didn't agree with Trump on immigration
completely and they were these guys were
masters appeal Oh mister present you're
gonna get that but you got it past this
tax cut right oh you you'll get what you
want and you're spending but you just
got to put this in the spending bill
first
and they snookered basically they
snookered him because Trump is I mean
look he was a political novice he didn't
actually know about how policy was made
in Washington DC it's [ __ ]
complicated it matters a lot who the
Deputy Secretary of Commerce is like you
and I aren't gonna know that person's
name that person's certified certifies
like steel tariffs yeah I still think
that's letting him off the hook too much
though because like I mean you see in
this in this crisis right if he may he
may have some instincts he may have some
ideological leanings and you're right
he's been talking about this some of
this stuff especially on trade for a
long time but when it came down to it
you know he was the first people he
called in the coronavirus crisis for
economic response were corporate CEOs
Wall Street executives like that's who
we went to to get his advice that's who
I trusted and that's how you end up you
know floating ideas like we're gonna
have a capital gains tax cut as a
response to the crisis or we're gonna
have a payroll tax cut which okay if you
have a range of responses maybe that's
part of it but when you've got 40
million people who aren't on a payroll
anymore that's not gonna do a whole heck
of a lot of good so I just don't see
that there's any maybe he has the
ideology but doesn't really matter if
you're not willing to push for if you're
not and you see who's organized in the
town because immediately once this
crisis hit immediately the first Trilly
multi trillion dollar bill gets passed
very very quickly with all the goodies
for big business this stuff that was
custom written every got their goodies
there was a massive tax break for real
estate developers that they tried to get
into the corporate bailout that they
and all ready to go like those are the
forces that are all completely organized
locked and loaded and ready to go in a
crisis and so they basically won I mean
they rolled everyone they tied the
little bit of poultry small business and
worker stuff to the massive corporate
piece and held the workers and the small
businesses hostage and so if you vote
don't vote for it
then you're voting against workers and
it was all ready to go like that and
that is what you were overcoming in the
town that sort of bipartisan 98 Oh 9800
I think when you're talking about Trump
in his history of understanding trade
and in business decisions I think it's
all stuff that benefited him that's why
he was concentrating on them and I think
now you're dealing with him spread so
thin because now he has to deal with the
environment he has to deal with
international politics and there's so
much and that's why you you catch him
and I think what you said too that he
lives off the it'd I mean I think that's
very true and he's always in the moment
right he famously said he just lives off
of his instincts he trusts his instincts
yeah which is great but he had
preparation when he was dealing with
those things before when he's talked
about those things before he was
president that's why I had a deeper
understanding of him because they meant
something to him yeah but now you're
dealing with the entire broad spectrum
of duties of being the president and he
says [ __ ] like inject people with Lysol
and sick dogs on protesters he's saying
nutty things right she's the strong man
right he's always been the strong man
he's always been the you're fired guy
right and he's still planet yes yes so
he's that guy now but he's that guy with
global thermonuclear consequences and so
that even more to the point on that
which is that when you don't have this
is this is another kind of establishment
always wins point is that when you don't
have very firm beliefs because like
trade and immigration are two things
were like hundreds of billions of
dollars behind the kernel liberal trade
and immigration policy that we have
right now in this country when you don't
have that a very well formed ideology
around how it should be like you're
saying on the environment or anything
else that is how they win because stats
status quo always continues in DC unless
you make the very concerted effort of
like no you are not doing this anymore
and I am appointing your boss and your
boss's boss and your boss's boss's
boss's boss in order to make sure that
you don't actually do that that's that's
actually what the hardest way to fight
back is you actually need a coherent
ideology on every single one of these
things but more important you got to
understand how government works and I
think that so many people don't seem to
grasp that it's not just like putting a
guy in the Oval Office like look by the
time it's reached the Oval Office it's
so [ __ ] right that ten levels down
they would have made the decision so
that's the power right like you got to
make sure that you're what you want is
being reflected ten layers down in the
bureaucracy and you look at the way you
know like Russia gate and all this other
stuff and you can just see like how
arrogant some of the people within the
bureaucracy behave just blatantly you
know disregarding the will of a
president or blatantly just thinking
he's illegitimate trying to deal legit
amazing and from that perspective that's
[ __ ] scary because they're not even
accountable to the person that we all
voted for
[Applause]